on behalf of uh our friends uh at rocket
mortgage and their
super bowl uh competition near squares
competition
uh pro football hall of famer barry
sanders here on the rich eisen joe how
are you barry
rich i'm will how's it going see i'm
great if only you had a little james
harden in your back of the day
you could just you know you could have
just gone up to the microphone after a
loss and just say
it's not going to work here with wayne
fonts i'm out you know and and and who
knows what would have happened right
barry
we just don't have the players guys you
know we don't have it
we don't have the players we don't have
the coaches no i mean
yeah that's a lot that you're right man
i think uh
i think their handwriting's on the wall
yeah
i mean it's certainly i mean did did you
ever
i know we always go there and i'm sure
you're sick and tired of talking about
it but you know i hope you don't mind
did you ever think of doing that back in
your day with the lines like
like how how close did you come publicly
to calling everything out um as opposed
to just saying you're done
playing how close did you do that barry
that would have been a reach for me
uh rich because i just um
my mind was somewhere else man i mean um
at the very end i just was was done
playing so
so i knew it was time to move on but
before that i was
preoccupied with just playing the game
and
and uh trying to be great at what i what
i did and try
trying to you know really build detroit
into
into something um you know and we we got
halfway there but
but yeah that would have been that would
have been a reach for me because my mind
just wasn't there
i mean i i cuz i loved playing the game
and it didn't
it almost didn't matter um what stadium
you put me in
especially initially um as a as a young
player
i was just excited to be on the field um
you know and so uh and then i like being
detroit
because it was a chance to to turn it
into a winner right
um i knew it we didn't inherit a winner
but it was a it was a
chance to change the narrative you know
we had to pick the big
saying back then you know restore the
roar you know so
that's what i was trying to do well
certainly since you didn't say
much and you you hardly ever spoke uh a
crossword like that it would have
resonated i don't know if you saw
on twitter yesterday what andre johnson
tweeted out did you see that barry
did you see it yeah yeah something to
the effect of you know just support
supporting watson yeah and and calling
out
the owner basically you know not by name
but say that some in the organization
for some reason can't seem to see what's
going on that i hope
desean will stand my ground i mean you
know andre i mean my gosh
he never says anything and that was out
of nowhere right bear i mean
that's that's something else out of him
oh yeah no
it again i think for him um it must
he must really be fed up with it for him
to
uh to make that kind of a statement um
you know
and so when you worn the uniform you
know you um
is a different level of care you know
and
and um an attachment that you have with
the organization and so
and so yeah i think um some guys it's
hard
you know you can't just stand by um and
watch in the organization
do things that you believe are are
against
um their best interests i guess so so
yeah i mean some some players are just
compelled to speak out and i think
that's what
andre did yesterday barry sanders pro
football hall of famer you're part of
the process of
uh putting pieces back together for the
lines right now right barry did i read
that
you're helping us that's right i mean
i'm i'm um i'm just sort of uh
you know sort of a support role um maybe
you could say i mean
obviously sheila she's tapped chris
filming
um to pretty much make the call um and
interview
coaches and and that kind of thing um
and so
uh and so yeah i mean
uh in some small way i'm involved in the
process
um you know and chris has a great uh
feel for the game he's been around the
game obviously for many years and
and being in the booth you know you you
understand who the
who the real actors are um you know from
a coaching standpoint
and and uh and that thing so he's
working diligently on it
um you know and and uh i'm um
you know i'm just sort of uh on the
fringes i guess you could say
sure uh and as uh some support
and maybe to bounce ideas off of um
so yeah that that's correct so let me
bounce off of you who do you think
not you know if you don't want to name
names that's fine but the the type
of coach the necessary traits
for the lions right here and right now
in 2021 would be what
who barry well i think there's some
some good candidates out there um
they've already
chris has already interviewed several
but i think going back to kind of um
kind of our my theory coming in as as a
lion
now someone who says i love the
opportunity
of trying to make detroit a winner whose
season has an opportunity um
who um who has a proven record who you
know and you have to be able to command
that locker room
um you know because you have all
different types
uh in there a lot of guys maybe who
haven't won
um and so you really you really have to
be able to challenge that group of men
uh to really prioritize um
certain things maybe that they haven't
prioritized before you know so that's
always
uh difficult um and so uh and so
i think some of those things um are what
chris was looking for and what i i guess
um
i would say could be good qualities um
someone who really
can command that locker room and and
obviously you gotta
you gotta know your exes and o's uh but
uh but you have to be someone who people
don't mind following
um you know and so and so yeah i mean um
hopefully that's that's uh kind of what
um
you know what we'll end up with um you
know and i think chris has a great
process in place
uh and and uh you know so we have a lot
of confidence in them and we're looking
forward to
the decisions that chris and ultimately
sheila
um comes up with do you think um chris
should um if you or he uh make it a
requirement of every coach coming in
that they make sure that their plan
involves matthew stafford
barry sanders i mean i would i would
assume that
it does involve matthew but that's me um
i don't know how some uh other coach
may uh may see that situation um but i
think he's still playing at a
tremendously high level
um couldn't see him stay healthy last
year
um and you know he i mean um he's just
been
he's carried the franchise for many
years and
and um and so you know just me looking
at it i would i would assume
he would he would fit into someone's
plans um
but uh but you know you can never say
for sure and you know again i know it's
somebody else's house but we were
talking about houston with the texans
and everything else going on there
and a name that's being bandied about as
a finalist for the job who i think would
be able to put
some of this fire whatever's going on we
don't know the extent of it with with
watson out would be jim caldwell
i wonder what you thought of of jim
and what he he might be able to bring to
that equation from the outside looking
in obviously as we are
so you're saying bringing back coach
caldwell that call well it looks like is
on the texans list
right now no no no
i i did say that you know initially
first blush when patricia was fired and
i got a whole bunch of crap from lions
twitter and people saying that jim
that jim didn't beat teams that had
winning records and there were like nine
guys on the field once and things like
that but
uh you you're hearing his name a lot and
and to me certainly down in houston
um that wouldn't surprise me that
wouldn't surprise me i mean look at
look at who he's been around right i
mean
you know look at um you know what he was
able to accomplish
um in indy you know and then i believe
he was on the staff
with um with the ravens when they won
super bowl uh he was on the staff and
even
his he has a winning record i thought he
did pretty well in detroit
um you know and and so uh it takes time
to build a winner you know so
so uh i think he can be somewhat proud
of what he was able to accomplish here
in detroit
um you can i guess you can always look
at it from any angle you want
um but uh but yeah that doesn't surprise
me that
that um you know that the texans
uh are looking at him i think he's a
solid candidate
um you know and and uh and really knows
the game
and and really so so yeah you know it
wouldn't surprise me at all
barry sanders here on behalf of uh
rocket mortgage super bowl square
sweepstakes which we'll get to in a
second
best running back in the league today
barry you get i think i might ask you
this every single time you're on but i
don't care it seems to change every year
right now who's the guy oh you mean
besides derek henry
okay no i mean i i hey congratulations
to derrick
um for the phenomenal year i i rich i
believe they should have given him the
ball
30 40 times uh last weekend
um you know i think he's still always
your best chance
on offense um you know so he's in a
tight game like that
he should have had many more carries uh
i know baltimore played him tough
um but what would you expect you know so
uh but anyway
but but a solid group of running backs
in the playoffs and
and even uh this season you know you
look at dalvin cook
the season he had and look at jonathan
taylor um
you know even um even with tampa with
with green bay the aaron jones kid over
a thousand yards i mean the
list goes on and on i mean look at
cleveland with chubb and
cream hunt um you know and and um
you know you look at kansas city even
with how the fireworks
uh that that offense is and edward de
lair and and the left bale i mean it's
just
you know so so um it was it was a good
year for running backs
um but obviously a great year for
derrick henry yeah i mean two thousand
yards
if that game went into overtime barry he
might have set the single game
and single season rushing records in one
day it was close
he was that good that day unstoppable
yeah absolutely absolutely
no i agree with you i agree with you
yeah i mean and his team needed every
one of those yards too you know so kudos
to him for
for stepping up but i love that there
she's a bit other than derek
yeah and it is amazing when you look at
cook i know he missed a couple games and
and um and jonathan taylor they they
weren't they were they weren't even
within 700
cook was i think 700 yards behind henry
and and uh
and taylor was almost a thousand yards
behind him that's how far henry was in
front of the rest of the field
this year no yeah i mean he almost
pretty much uh mostly everyone else
besides cook
you know so but the guy uh in my opinion
rich lat the last couple years you know
he's been the most dominant player
outside of patrick mahomes and maybe
arguably
aaron rodgers um you know so hopefully
he's being compensated
and with that you know in that range of
quarterback money i don't know what what
his particular deal is
right but uh he's certainly deserving of
it and how many yards would you have
gotten in a season with a fullback
barry how many certainly all you mean
back
back then yes back then with it with a
good fallback
you know i think strong strong year you
know come on wrong yeah give me a number
give me a number give you a number how
about how about 1900
oh come on give me i wanted to give you
to give me the number
beyond eric dickerson so the two of you
could have a nice conversation the next
time you saw each other
you know oh yeah i'm sure derek you uh
oh i'm not eric would very really
appreciate that i'm sure
um you know i but no hey look eric man
you know just a wonderful runner and i'm
sure he loves uh
he loves to see guys get close but but
not too close exactly he was probably
wherever he was on that week 17
sunday he was rooting for that game not
to go to overtime and he was probably
jumping out of a seat when somebody
knocked the ball out of henry's hand
because if he didn't fumble it on that
carry in the fourth quarter he was go
he got 50 yards in front of him he would
have said it maybe on that run alone
unbelie he really is amazing no
absolutely man no he
he has such a bright future and i i
wouldn't be surprised to see him
go over 2000 um you know even again in
the future
to be the only guy to do it twice um you
know but i think he's just that good
so before i let you go barry i'm reading
a promo uh
about this on nfl game day morning every
single uh playoff weekend now and i plan
to do it i'm
probably got a few more shows left in at
the rocket mortgage super bowl squares
sweepstakes that you're free to enter
right now i'll give you the floor on it
barry what do you got for me on this oh
yeah yeah rich i mean it's just a chance
for
for fans to win a lot of cash uh during
the game and so um
every score change during the game
rocket mortgage
is gonna give away um fifty thousand
dollars
uh to fans and then the grand prize
consists of
a couple of fans having a chance to win
half a million dollars
and so as i said before every score
change field goals touchdowns equal
points whatever
um you have a chance to win 50 grand and
so you can go to
rocketmortgagesquares.com and find out
more about it as you mentioned it is
free to play
um great way to just be involved in
super bowl
um in addition to obviously being the
world's greatest game
um you know rocket mortgage is just
building on what they did last year and
giving away um 1.7 million dollars to
fans
um you know and so hopefully this year
is even bigger and better
than that so uh again go to
rocketmortgagesquares.com
uh to find out more about it maybe you
you can be a lucky winner
and and i think everybody when they do
that they need to learn their analytics
because as you mentioned you know it's
every score change
so if you've got the square that would
hit
if somebody tries the extra point and
then they trot out going for two
down like say 13 you have no idea what
the hell they're doing because of
analytics
and then suddenly that passes up your
shot to win the square i mean
that that that's that's going to hurt
i'm not going to lie that's going to
hurt everyone needs to understand the
math
and the analytics or something like this
they do but
there's plenty of chances to win though
rich every score changes
a lot of great offenses in in the
playoffs and and
and hopefully that'll make it to the
super bowls i know defensive
coordinators may not want to hear that
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i know
hey barry thanks for the call appreciate
it uh hope you're in your family you're
well
healthy and uh i always love our chats
you take care barry
you'll be welcome thanks rich great
great talking to you man got it you got
that's barry sanders right here on the
rich eisen show at barry sanders on
twitter instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here